pourquoi faisons-nous où nous allons c'est
exactement pourquoi ne pas s'arrêter et profiter de
lui
pour vider l'argent trop touristique est parti mais
qu'est-ce que tu fais ici à Paris regarde
c'est notre anniversaire de mariage et moi nous
avons du temps juste l'un pour l'autre idiot
toi '  J'ai fait bouillir mon sang comme personne d'
autre signe d'une connexion profonde une fois que les
enfants sont partis ce qui reste Beckett dit que
nous voulons dire l'amour quand nous disons l'amour que
voulez-vous dire d'autre est stupide ce que oh mon dieu Nick
ne peut pas ne pas aimer et détester la même personne
vraiment c'est généralement en l'espace de
cinq minutes d'après mon expérience je pense que
nous avons des
gens ne changent pas ils ont
empiré les gens faites le s'il vous plait vous manquez voici
la facture qui est pas mal d'argent
ne dites pas aux enfants
qu'elle a gelé  est-ce que j'ai trouvé hier en train d'embrasser
passionnément une femme dans la rue, il
a affirmé plus tard que cette femme était sa
femme
voici les problèmes futurs disent
divorce mort ah papa
qui sait vivre ailleurs
toi Celeste
essaie-moi encore et je promets que ce sera plus
amusant ça